division as well but also the lectern
and of course she will be speaking when
she appears at some point in the
not-too-distant future we presume as as
leader of the Conservatives which is why
we don't have the the seal of the Prime
Minister on the lectern what can she
possibly say at this juncture as
everyone leans forward as someone
emerges from the front door a number
said what can she possibly say beyond a
very simple straightforward reaction to
the fact that there has now been
something of a challenge to a leadership
well I think if you have those in
advising her right now in number 10 will
be saying to her obviously goes without
saying she's going to come out fighting
at that lectern I think you will get a
challenge laid down not to the European
research groups core that have led to
this vote but to perhaps the next few
dozen of MPs who don't like the the
smell of the withdrawal agreement that
she has brought back from Brussels don't
like the idea of the sorts of limited
concessions she can plausibly get out of
the European Union but she will try to
appeal to them with the specter frankly
I think of a chaotic need to delay
article 50 of what this looks like to
the country she'll remind the
conservative MPs that divided parties
don't get elected and the memories of
the public of these types of events they
linger long in the memory of the public
them so I think that that will be the
sort of appeal she will try to make I
think her challenge here is that she
does seem to be at or very near the end
of the road in what she can negotiate in
terms of her path on brexit she was the
one that set her own red lines she finds
herself frankly tangled in those red
lines right now it was her approach that
led to this situation and now she's
trying to sell a deal that does
not have the support of the majority of
Tory back benches and does not have the
support of a number of Ministers
privately to junior ministers who are
not particularly comfortable of where
this is going I think she just has to
appeal to those more pragmatic Breck
suitors about what the consequences of
this will be yes you're going for your
perfect pure brexit WTO terms what they
call clean brexit but in so doing
are you not risking brexit at all the
problem though with that approach is she
has tried that already she tried that in
order to corral MPs behind her deal in
the first place and that failed
spectacularly with the result of that
humiliating need to withdraw the actual
vote in the first place so I would say
it is going to be quite tough for her
clearly she is fighting for her job she
will rail against the chances of a
Jeremy Corbyn government she will do the
same at Prime Minister's Questions that
is what she will have to do when we see
her appearing essentially not as Prime
Minister but as leader of the
Conservative Party but I just we should
step back a little bit if we can from
the drama of today this is extraordinary
stuff this is the sort of splits now
that is not just about a person's resume
it is about a fundamental approach to
this historic exits from the European
Union with a Conservative Party that may
well have irreconcilable splits you know
parties have splits on smaller issues
than the historic issue now facing this
country and this in a way is very
important in terms of who's the Prime
Minister news leader of the Conservative
Party but it's super important of course
in terms of the country . the question
for me is whether a whole tsunami of
discontent from other matters from her
approach to the economy from her
occasion her team's occasional lack of
engagement with business from her
decision to call an election that was
then botched
from those people who fear that if they
don't act now this Prime Minister will
see brexit through will be
unchallengeable for a further 12 months
and then she is all the way through to
the next election so a number of
different considerations neil i find so
many thanks of course as we continue to
monitor events in darlinks we expect the
prime minister in the not-too-distant
future let's get some reaction from
brussels skies diplomat together to a
dominic y con joins us from there I mean
if you manage to take the temperature I
mean they said was always a possibility
wasn't it Dominic and I'm and I'm
certain that those who work in and
around Brussels at we're aware of it
yeah I mean we haven't had any official
reaction yet no one's speaking publicly
yet in terms of officials here but I
think we can guess their reaction as
they wake up to the news on Sky News and
their own media today they will I think
be aghast at the shenanigans going on at
all in Westminster we've been saying
they've been amused by what's been going
on that the chaos of the withdrawal
agreement not being put to the Commons
this mad dash desperate to buy Theresa
may in a sense they've been boom use but
possibly not entirely surprised because
they are obviously seasoned diplomats
and politicians here they understand
British politics and it's not been
entirely unpredictable what's been
happening in the UK they've always known
it's a possibility that this agreement
and the whole brexit saga could cause
such a division in the Tory party that
this could happen having said that I
think they will be shocked still there
will be worries and they will be aghast
as I say about what is going on I think
the big concern is the Jeopardy for
European officials have been negotiating
with the Prime Minister is that if she
goes this with the drawl agreement goes
as well and the chances of a No Deal
brexit are much higher there isn't a
huge amount of enthusiasm for the
agreement and in the sense that it's a
negotiated compromise so people are
enthusiastic about it because it's a
compromise it's a way out of this it has
been torturously negotiated over two
years and there are concerns on all
sides you know not everyone is happy
with
all of it that's fair to say but it is
the best option
the only possible deal as jean-claude
juncker the the EU Commission president
put it yesterday and so I think hanging
on to resumes future is the future of
the widget all agreement and the only
deal possible that many people here feel
is is a feasible outcome for the Brest
negotiations so I think they'll be
deeply concerned now about the
possibility of that going and worried
about what happens to the Prime Minister
and relations with the UK and what
happens frankly to the British
government and the British Conservative
Party I think you know in terms of the
timetable Teresa may was due here
tomorrow she still do here tomorrow the
the EU summit begins tomorrow afternoon
at 2 o'clock ahead of that Donald terse
the EU council president has said they
set aside time we think it's ahead of
the summit at least for an article 15
sort of emergency summit to discuss
what's been going on with Brett suit in
the UK Theresa mace not invited to that
but obviously she could come along if
she is invited but she will be going to
the summit after that now if she loses
tonight the assumption most people
making is that even if she loses as
leader of the Conservative Party she
carries on as Prime Minister but she
will be arriving here effectively as a
kind of zombie prime minister a a
political equivalent to the walking dead
and what she then does in that capacity
has to be guessed at so it's all up in
the air now Adam I think we're still
looking at that leptin outside number 10
Downing Street we're still waiting
waiting for reaction from Brussels but I
think it's fair to say there will be a
lot of concern amongst people here who
have been working with the Prime
Minister through thick and thin to make
this that Brett's that negotiations
reach as far as they have now concerned
that all their efforts would have been
for naught
dominate thank you very much indeed as
you can see as Dominic was saying there
the lectern without a crest which is
normal when personal political
statements are being made by the Prime
Minister being readied for her with mr.
Graham Brady who is of course the
chairman of the 1922 committee and scram
in very simple terms you are in charge
for now what's going to happen to
process was very simple if 15% of my
colleagues and the House of Commons on
the conservative benches wrote to me as
chairman of a new committee requesting a
vote of confidence in the leader of the
party there and it was incumbent on me
to discuss that with the leader of the
party which I did last night on the
telephone and then to move to a ballots
as soon as is practicable in the
circumstances Prime Minister's very keen
that we should move rapidly clearly
wants resolution as soon as possible so
he made the announcement you know the
this morning she will come and speak to
colleagues for 1922 to committee this
afternoon at 5:00 and the ballot would
take place immediately after that
meeting between 6 and 8 o'clock with the
result they cleared as soon as we are
able to perceive actually 14 the big
commits a big big committee room and SP
clear what this is an election for this
is what leader the parliamentary party
leader of the Conservative Party and
therefore whatever the result tonight
were it to go gates mrs. may she would
for the time being continuous Prime
Minister that's right it's one of the
great things about the British
constitution that it can absorb all
sorts of of things happening so so it is
possible for a Prime Minister to lose an
elections leader of the Conservative
Party lose a ballot on leadership of the
Conservative Party remain Prime Minister
until such time as a successor is
elected by the party and without
prejudice really were she to lose a vote
of confidence what would then happen
would you then be organizing the neck I
should say first of all if she wins the
post of confidence then there is a
12-month period in which no further vote
of confidence could be held if she were
to lose the vote of confidence then she
would cease to be leader of the
Conservative Party and it would be for
me to begin the process of organizing an
election for
new leader who would go on to become
Prime Minister and this is something
that would first of all entail some
parliamentary stages where conservative
members of parliament would choose our
two preferred candidates obviously we
would seek to do that as quickly as
possible and then it would go out by
postal ballot to all of the members of
the Conservative Party in the country I
can't be precise we could do the
parliamentary stages which would be
entirely in the hands of me and the 19
Tory to do committee executive really
quite quickly in 2016 it took no more
than 10 days it would be possible to do
it more quickly than that and then the
the process of a postal ballot around
the country would need to be by
discussion agreement with the board of
the Conservative Party it depends how
many hustings meetings they wanted to
have and things like that
of course last time around he'd end up
there was only one candidate so that
that short-circuited the process do you
think that's likely this time around
it's really impossible to predict what
happened last time was that the
candidates in second place Andrea let
some was significantly behind the
candidates in first place the process
that had been set out by the
Conservative Party board was quite a
long one being proposed then and I think
I was probably one of the factors that
led and really led them to think it was
in the in the national interest not to
proceed it is of course a minority of
Tory MPs are needed to trigger this and
only 15% you sound out the party more
broadly do you think there was a feeling
that with just 106 days to go until
rigidly leaving the European Union this
was the best way of using political time
I I think that will become clear when
votes are cast this evening and
obviously colleagues have to weigh up
the situation way up all of their
preferences but it is of course it's a
relatively small part of the
parliamentary conservative party 15
percent that is required to trigger a
confidence vote and as you know as well
as anybody there's been speculation
going on for months as to whether that
trigger had been
asked we've read in newspapers that
xlviii had been reached certainly
several weeks ago I've heard it from so
many people who and I was the only
person who would know how you were able
to tell us exactly how many letters
though I know I don't think I wear it
and it's not required and the rules the
rules simply say that when the threshold
is is exceeded because it needs to be at
least 15% of the parliamentary party but
of course it's a fluid process as well
people can withdraw less as well as
putting them in so therefore it took a
little time to be clear exactly what was
happening and when that point now who
exactly gets to vote everybody whether
they're Minister on the government
payroll or not in the Conservative Party
yesterday the speaker does he ever heard
no all conservative members of
parliament in receipt of the
Conservative Party width which would
exclude the speaker who of course stands
for election as Speaker
not as a Conservative member of
parliament though he was originally a
conservative number five and anyone
who's suspended as well anybody who said
that would be mr. Elphie who remains to
be seen whether decisions have been
taken in relation to particular
individuals but they would have to be in
receipt of the conservative whip in
order to participate and the ballot and
see and and talk us through the ballot
is this bits of paper or is it black
balls and white balls I mean how does it
work I'm sorry to dissapoint it with
pieces of paper like most ballots that
that take place like all of the the
viewers are used to putting across in a
box on a on a ballot paper well we're
just waiting for the prime minister to
come out she wants to you to come out a
while ago but as we've seen during this
particular political crisis it has often
been that things have been running late
as you can see the lectern there in
front of the Christmas tree
what are your constituents telling about
this I mean they know you've got
shop steward of the Tory Party one of
those things that mean do they think
this is a good idea this I I think the
experience of politics at the moment
perhaps especially if you started
getting into the politics of our
relationship with the European Union you
get almost as many opinions as there are
individuals so members of parliament are
not short of advice from our
constituents but the advice frequently
conflicts I just sing there one of the
Prime Minister's aides
I think testing the microphones and
telling the cameras what's going to
happen there isn't going to be as there
isn't normally on this question I
understand any questions to the prime
minister she she will just be making a
statement
now what about government business
because this is after all the moment
where government is trying to get in the
Greek position on leaving the European
Union if there were to be and I know
you're not saying there is but if there
were to be no confidence in the Prime
Minister tonight can't can parliamentary
debate continue I think parliamentary
debate can continue the business of
government continues and it's part of
the genius of the British constitution
that there is always a prime minister
the Prime Minister will remain in office
until another prime minister is in
office so I think there will be a degree
of seamlessness to things regardless of
what happened it's a big question
obviously it's going to be what's
happening about the various bits of
European legislation because clearly
this is what's brought this to a head
and I think this inevitably is one of
the reasons why the Prime Minister was
very keen that this matter should be
resolved as quickly as possible
and you know I obviously was keen to
facilitate that by making sure that we
get through this process today and if we
were to go into a leadership contest
beyond Parliament in the
tree it's at the moment to ask the
European Union to stop the clock on me
things you think well I would love to
debate all of these issues with you Adam
of perhaps another time I think it's
quite important today that I remain
neutral and independent obviously I have
a member of parliament I have my own I
have a vote I guess I'm not going to say
anything I think importing this process
people both my colleagues and the wider
the Conservative Party but I think the
country as a whole has a right to expect
that this process will be conducted in a
scrupulous the fair and independent way
and that will be my focus today rather
than giving my own views on matters of
public policy she's extraordinary isn't
it going back to Margaret Thatcher how
this question of Europe has put
successive deserved apparently with into
jeopardy we could go now to the Prime
Minister sir Graham Brady has confirmed
but he has received 48 letters from
Conservative MPs so there will now be a
vote of confidence in my leadership of
the Conservative Party
I will contest that vote with everything
I've got I have been a member of the
Conservative Party for over 40 years
I've served it as an activist
councillor MP Shadow Minister Home
Secretary and now as Prime Minister I
stood to be leader because I believe in
the conservative vision for a better
future a thriving economy with nowhere
and nobody left behind a stronger
society where everyone can make the most
of their talents always serving the
national interest and at this crucial
moment in our history that means
securing a brexit deal that delivers on
the result of the EU referendum taking
back control of our borders laws and
money but protecting jobs our security
and our precious union as we do so
through good times and bad over the last
two years my passionate belief that such
a deal is attainable that a bright
future lies ahead for our country has
not wavered and it is now within our
grasp I spent yesterday meeting
Chancellor Merkel Prime Minister Rutter
President tusk and president Janka to
address the concerns that MPs have with
the backstop and we are making progress
I was due to travel to Dublin this
afternoon to continue that work but will
now remain here in London to make the
case for my leadership with my
parliamentary colleagues a change of
leadership in the Conservative Party now
will put our country's future at risk
and create uncertainty when we can least
afford it
a new leader wouldn't be in place by the
21st of January legal deadline so a
leadership election risks handing
control of the brexit negotiations to
opposition MPs in Parliament the new
leader wouldn't have time to renegotiate
a withdrawal agreement and get the
legislation through Parliament by the
29th of March so one of their first acts
would have to be extending or rescinding
article 50 delaying or even stopping
brexit when people want us to get on
with it and a leadership election would
not change the fundamentals of the
negotiation or the parliamentary
arithmetic weeks spent tearing ourselves
apart will only create more division
just as we should be standing together
to serve our country
none of that would be in the national
interest
the only people whose interest would be
served are Jeremy Corbyn and John
McDonald the British people want us to
get on with it and they want us to focus
on the other vital issues that matter to
them - building a stronger economy
delivering first-class public services
and the homes that families need these
are the public's priorities and they
must be the Conservative Party's
priorities - we must and we shall
deliver on the referendum vote and seize
the opportunities that lie ahead but the
Conservatives must not be a single issue
party we are a party of the whole nation
moderate pragmatic mainstream committed
to reuniting our country and building a
country that works for everyone
the agenda I set out in my first speech
outside this front door delivering the
brexit people voted for building a
country that works for everyone I have
devoted myself unsparingly to these
tasks ever since I became Prime Minister
and I stand ready to finish the job
so the Prime Minister they're saying I
will contest that vote with everything
I've got
she's canceled her planned trip to
Dublin to see the Irish Prime Minister
so that she can speak to colleagues but
the big message to the MPs the
Conservative MPs the 316 who are going
to take the decision about her future
tonight if she says if you spark a
leadership contest now that will almost
certainly lead to having to delay or
even call off the brexit process and she
also said that power the real control of
what happens in Parliament will shift
from the governing party from the
Conservatives to the opposition who
probably will be able to command the
votes on a vote of confidence or on
anything else and the other point mrs.
Mae made